well it's happening the escalation of
antagonism between Donald Trump and
China is happening last week I told you
about this phone call that Donald Trump
made with Taiwan and of course when he
took that phone call with sighing when
he broke what were decades of diplomatic
practice where the United States
officially only has diplomatic relations
with China not recognizing Taiwan as a
separate entity Trump on Fox News Sunday
said I don't know why we have to be
bound by a one China policy unless we
make a deal with China having to do with
other things including trade well it
took only a few days the Communist Party
controlled press in China there's a
newspaper called the Global Times now I
don't know when I say the word tabloid
that has maybe a particular meaning to
some people but what I mean by it by
saying that the Global Times is a
tabloid it's known for being a communist
party controlled propaganda of sorts
they wrote that Donald Trump is quote as
ignorant as a child saying Trump should
maybe read up on us-china relations they
warned that if Trump makes the u.s.
abandoned the one China policy that
Beijing would have no reason to quote
put peace above using force to take back
Taiwan we're awaiting Trump's response
on Twitter about this maybe it'll be
something like know you're acting like
the child China Global Times has also
mocked Obama so this is not a Trump only
thing the difference though is that
Donald Trump is actually setting up some
serious antagonism of China Trump knows
so little that the concern is that he's
stepping into a hornet's nest without
having any idea about it but the good
news Pat is that least Donald Trump is
going to surround himself with really
sensible advisors and a great team to
help him run the country and deal with
foreign policy oh wait a second he's
hiring oil CEOs climate china change
deniers and Russian friends and the
generals he claimed to be smarter than
during the campaign
maybe we do actually have to be worried
about Trump in China I think we do I
mean I think I think some of the
positions that Donald Trump is taking on
China including going against the one
China policy and against the
manipulating their currency those
concerns are valid but there's a more
diplomatic approach that you can take to
address them rather than just go out on
Twitter because that's gonna experience
a lot of backlash not only that you can
have a valid concern but still
completely misunderstand what you're
supposed policy ideas would do to either
fix or make that problem even worse and
that's one of the major concerns that
Trump is tapped into grains of truth
with a lot of these issues but then is
proposing so-called solutions that in
many cases would only make the problem
much worse very very scary please check
out david pakman.com slash donate the
crowdfunding campaign is on Warby Parker
is offering a free five day home Tryon
to give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trialed
dot-com slash TDP s I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home Tryon I was able to pick
five pairs that I liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I liked the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like $300 for prescription
glasses hi which is just insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing